so hi again
um what we're going to do now is we're
going to have a look at r
um doing data analysis these days
definitely requires a very good
Computing environment and there's lots
around but from my point of view R is is
probably the best environment
these days R is free as we've mentioned
before and and it's got a vast range of
capabilities
and there's it's got quite a steep
learning curve but the more you learn
the more capable you become
so R allows you to do all all kinds of
basic operations and data and it's also
got lots of built-in packages
and once you learn R you'll discover
it's also got very beautiful graphics
and after a while you'll find that you
start writing functions yourself and
expanding your abilities
so really R and or tools like our
fundamental to doing good data analysis
and statistical modeling and so we've
we're making this a central part of the
of this course
so what I'm doing here is I'm actually
running R in another free program called
rstudio so that's just an environment
for running R and for developing
presentations in our and it's convenient
for giving a presentation of this kind
so we'll uh we'll now go to a
introductory session in our studio and
I'll just show you some of the features
of r
so here we are you'll see I've got a
script in the rstudio session in the top
left panel and in the bottom left panel
there's the r working session and what's
going to happen is I'm going to I'm
going to click on commands that I've
pre-entered and they'll get sent to the
r session window and execute it now of
course I could have tried to to do this
live and just type in the commands but I
don't touch type and that would have
been painful for you and me
so here we go so the first thing we'll
do is just see working with basic
vectors and and matrices
so here we assign three numbers to a
vector X
and you see the commands gone down below
and if we just type X it'll print the
vector and there we see the three
numbers now there's many ways of
creating vectors so here's another way
making a sequence starting from 4 and
having length 3 and in steps by three so
that's a kind of natural thing one would
want to do
um this command seek is actually very
useful and if you want to find out more
about it in R the way to get help on
functions and objects is to put a
question mark in front so we do question
mark seek and in our studio on the right
panel we see the panel comes up giving
us all the options for seek and you'll
see there's quite a few options in the
command seek that let you make sequences
in in flexible ways
if we type if we type y we see the
values and as you might have expected we
see 4 7 and 10. so now we've got two
vectors X and Y both have the same
length and now we can do things with
them and R does Vector operations in
parallel so if we say X Plus y even
though they're both vectors we get the
sum of those two vectors element by
element and likewise other operations
like X slash y means X divide Y and it
does element wise division of the
elements and you can do x to the power Y
and it'll do element wise exponentiation
that gave us a rather big number over
there
so that's some simple operations for
creating vectors
what about accessing elements of vectors
well so there's a subscript in
convention in R using Square braces so x
squared Race 2 gives us the second
element of x
if we go x squared raised 2 colon 3 that
says we want the elements of X starting
from element 2 and ending at element 3.
okay so it gives us the two values and a
very convenient
option in in R for subsetting is to put
negative signs in subscripts so x minus
2 means remove the element 2 from X and
return the subsetted vector and so there
we see that's done and you can remove
more than one element at a time and so
here we move in the collection of
indices one and two and they can be an
arbitrary collection of indices and that
just gives us a vector of length one
um something to note there's no scalars
in R everything's a vector so a scale is
just a vector of length one
okay so those are vectors the next
higher up object we we're interested in
our matrices
so matrices
um and there's a is a case of an array
we you can have high dimensional arrays
as well in r a matrix is a two-way array
and here's a simple way of making a
matrix so here we've got Z is equal to a
matrix and we give it the numbers 1 to
12. so the first argument is are the
actual numbers in The Matrix and then we
give it the dimensions four and three so
we want to make a four by three Matrix
and there it is and so it you see it's
taken the numbers in in column order
which is the convention in r
and so now just like with vectors we can
subset elements of a matrix so here we
want to see the the third and fourth row
and the second and third column
and there we go
and if you if you put just put a comma
and ignore the first index you'll you'll
just get the columns so this gives us
the second and third column of Z
and there's the First Column of Z Now
notice what's happened when we
we took just the First Column of Z that
became a vector and it actually dropped
its Matrix status
sometimes that's convenient but a lot of
the time it's not especially when you
program in and you don't want to
accidentally lose the status of a matrix
so the Matrix subsetting has an argument
drop and here we say drop equals false
and it keeps that one column Matrix as a
matrix and not a vector
so there's various functions you can
query the dimension of the Matrix so dim
of Z gives you the the dimensions of the
Matrix
okay so those are vectors and matrices
um LS is a very nice command it tells
you what you have available in your
working directory and so we've got a
number of variables there the ones we've
just made are x y and z
um you can clean up your your your
working directory so for example you can
use the RM command to RM to remove Y and
here we see why it's gone okay
all right
so that's making making data
um sort of directly
there's other convenient way especially
in in statistics you're going to often
be doing simulations to test out
routines and to test out ideas and so we
need a a good Suite of tools for for
generating data
so runoff is random uniform so this
command will create 50 random uniforms
and on zero one
and our Norm is random Norm random
gaussians random normal variables it'll
create 50 standard random normal
variables
and let's look at a plot of these
variables and so we plot X and Y and
there we get a plot on the right
now I must I must say our Graphics is
really well designed one doesn't think
too much about the design of Graphics
but the lot goes into it such as aspect
ratios how much space to put around on
the points on a plot between the the
edge of the points and and the axes
uh just things like spacing of the axes
how many ticks and so on it all seems
like trivial details but it's not and
this has been carefully thought of and
and designed and therefore our Graphics
I think are particularly attractive
of course I may be a little inbradia
since I've been an RN and it's pretty
SAS user for many many years
so you can put or you can annotate your
plots and and add all kinds of features
to your plots so there's the same plot
but we change the plotting character and
we put axis labels and there's many many
options for plotting making plots
here's an option for um and and the par
command allows you to set some of these
options some you can do directly in the
plot command and some like layout
commands you can sit with par
so this is one that's often used mfro
um it says we want to make a plot with
um we want to have a panel of plots with
two rows and one column and so that we
do with the mfro command and so now if
we do the same plot in our plot region
you'll see it's a little squashed up now
because we want two plots in this region
and so in the in the second part of the
region we're going to do a histogram of
Y
um and so that mfro that that
um that division will stay in place
until you reset it with another mfo
command and so there we've we've reset
it
Okay so we've created data manually
we've generated data using random um
uniform number generators and we saw
uniform and normal and there's many
other distributions you can read you can
generate from
okay so now we're going to read in some
data that we've got in some other system
for example Excel is is often the place
where you store your data and um and so
we're going to read that there's ways of
doing that in R so we use the
read.csv function and so this requires
that you've saved your data in in comma
separated value from Excel and then you
can just read it in in R and it respects
the rows and columns and the headings
and everything else and of course you
need to know where the data is
um it's in this case I know where the
data is if if not you'll get an error
but yeah we do know what it is and so
now we can query the data that we have
in just read in and you can see it's got
a number of columns
um and those are the names of the
variables
and we can look at the dimension of the
data it's 397 by 9. and
we can see what is this object that
we've read in the the class of Auto is a
data frame and you'll learn more about
data frames they very um valuable
objects it's sort of like a matrix
except that the columns can be variables
of different kinds so you can have what
we call factors and continuous variables
and and matrices and and so on which is
really what the way we think of
observations in in statistics
summaries are useful function for for a
data frame it will give you a summary of
each of the variables in the data frame
and you can see as things like min max
and so on
horsepower for example is is a
categorical variable so it actually
gives you all the values and and the
name of of the the automobile is also
categorical it's a factor variable it
gives you the values
so data frames and summary of data
frames very useful
now you can you can plot the elements of
the data frame so data frame is also a
list
and a list you get the the elements of
the list by
given the name of the the list which is
auto here and then use a dollar sign and
then you can give the name so that's one
way of getting the the elements of a
list and so here we want to plot the
column cylinders against the column
miles per gallon MPG and so we do we
access both of those in the same way
and so there we have it there's a plot
and so you can see that cylinders also
takes on discrete values
um
and yeah we do cylinders against
um miles per gallon
so that's a little cumbersome having to
do that that in that dollar indexing of
of the elements of the data frame so
what you can actually do is you can
attach the data frame and attaches and
what it does is it creates a a workspace
with all the named variables as now
variables in your workspace so now you
can access them by name
okay and so if we do issue the command
search it tells us our various
workspaces and there we see the global
environment is where we've put all our
vectors like X Y and Z and the and the
variables we've we've created in the
session
but this data frame that we've attached
is in the second position here and it's
got the variables that are in in the
order data frame available for our
direct use and you'll see there's other
things in the search path as well and
these are largely packages at this point
whose functions we have available
so now we can do that plot command more
directly and
and yeah we've plotted um cylinders and
miles per gallon
and in this case it's plotted it as as a
box plot and we see for each level of
cylinders we get a box plot of the
values
um four miles per gallon which is like a
little one-dimensional summary of the of
the the variables
of the values at that level of cylinder